who is doing it right today who's who's
i mean obviously you got the chapelles
you got the rogans who else would you
put in the camp that is
pushing the envelope and not holding
back and who have you seen
has made major adjustments and gone and
become woke or soft any names in the
market you know the the amount that's oh
man the amount of shattered freud i had
watching all of new york city who for
10 years i i saw gradually descend into
this non-stop you know uh carrying water
for for the state you know they just
became the this woke hardcore leftist
activist sect and then they got shut
down
and they were like the government blew
me and i'm like oh oh
there's the government overreaching guys
can't go to work oh that's like so give
me names though like who do you think
like who's who's give the names of who
is pushing back today i'll tell you um
some look the guy jp sears jp series has
done an unbelievable job you know you
interviewed jp sears uh ryan long is
throwing a lot of jokes that are like
hilarious dude ryan long um bill maher
comments a lot on cancel culture and
he's very anticipated
who believes in freedom right believes
you you know he agrees with the left on
almost every issue the only the thing
that he doesn't agree with the left on
is uh this kind of authoritarian attempt
to silence anybody who disagrees with
them right so
and that applies to a lot of comedians
and he's felt a lot of pressure he he
faces calls to be canceled all the time
for the stuff that he says and mostly
what he's saying is stop cancel culture
and then cancel him for saying that
he'll say i can't stand trump i can't
stand what these guys are doing but
stop trying to cancel these guys what
they have to say because even back in
the days if you think about
those who were against censorship
were
representing the left now it's them who
want to censor so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you